momentan zuständige Probleme kommen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Ganz, Martin Ganz.
Herr Ganz, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 40 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 5. Mai 1982.
1982.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,70 m groß und 85 kg am schweren.
Herr Ganz, was für Sie zu uns?
Ich habe seit 2 Tagen starke Brustschmerzen.
Ich bin sehr besorgt.
Ein Bekannter von mir ist vor Kurzem an einem Herz gestorben.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt hier in der Ambulanz und möchte, dass ich gerne abgekehrt habe.
Wer ist an Herzinfarkt verstorben?
Ein Bekannter von mir.
Er ist auch recht jung gestorben.
Mit 45 Jahren ist er in Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Ich habe seit 2 Tagen starke Brustschmerzen.
Ich möchte gerne eine abgekehrt haben.
Es tut mir leid.
Ist das erste Mal aufgefallen bei Ihnen?
Ja, das erste Mal seit 2 Tagen.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich angefangen?
Ja, ja, doch, plötzlich ja.
Haben sich die Schmerzen in der Läufe derzeit verschlechtert?
Ich glaube, das wird mehr.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass es mehr wird.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einem Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 ist sehr leichter und 10 sehr starker, wenn ich im Herzen anspricht?
Es kommt darauf an.
Ich würde schon sagen, manchmal ist es mehr, manchmal weniger,
aber aktuell habe ich es ungefähr, so 6 bis 7, würde ich sagen.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, dass ich schlecht atmen könnte,
aber eigentlich nicht wirklich.
Ich habe zu Hause mein Blutdruck gemessen, der war auch okay.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie noch einmal den Blutdruck messen möchten,
aber der Blutdruck und so etwas war zu Hause okay.
Ich habe ein Blutdruckmessgerät, das war alles okay zu Hause,
aber trotzdem bin ich sehr, sehr besorgt.
Ich muss jetzt das Aufnahmegesiebräsch unterbrechen
und ich würde gerne Ihre Vitalparameter überprüfen
und ich werde Sie an der Monitor anschließen.
Das wäre super, ja.
Ich würde gerne Ihre Herzritmus und Herzstitution überprüfen.
Nein, nicht bekannt.
Okay, meine Kollegin,
kranken Sie Westa, wird Ihnen einige Schmerzmittel geben.
Danke schön, vielen Dank.
Okay, herzganz...
Aber ich brauche aktuell keine Schmerzmedikamentablöder.
Ich kann es aushalten so.
Okay, ja, sehr schön.
Sie haben gesagt, seit zwei Tagen,
sie hat sich ein sehr starkes Brustschmerz gefeiert.
Sie hat sich ein sehr starkes Brustschmerz gefeiert.
Sie haben noch andere Becher,
aber Sie haben gesagt, es ist keine Luftnote, Atemnote.
Manchmal habe ich schon etwas Gefühl,
dass ich nicht recht atmen kann,
wenn es sehr stark plötzlich kommt.
Aber so habe ich keine Atemgeschwerte.
Okay, haben Sie höchstens oder auswürfen?
Nein, ich habe keine höchsten, keine auswürfen, aber nein.
Okay, sind Sie mehr als in anderen Körperregionen?
Strahlen Sie sich mehr als in anderen Körperregionen?
Oder woher?
Sie sind hauptsächlich in der Brust, aber manchmal habe ich das Gefühl,
dass es im Rücken wäre.
Hab es auch Bauchschmerzen?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Okay, hängen die Schmerzen mit dem Essen zusammen?
Nein, habe ich jetzt auch nicht bemerkt.
Okay, haben Sie einen Auslöser bemerkt?
Zum Beispiel eine Belastung oder ein Sport?
Ich mache wenig Sport, ich habe das nicht so bemerkt, aber nein.
Also so richtig auch nicht.
Das kommt und geht dieser Schmerz.
Es kommt und geht immer wieder.
Es ist immer so nicht anhaltend.
Okay, das ist wie Well-and-formig oder Schub-formig?
Ja, kann man so sagen, es kommt und dann ist es mal gut.
Und dann geht es wieder.
Es ist nicht anhaltend.
Okay.
Wenn Sie laufen oder rennen, sind die Schmerzen auftreten.
Wenn ich laufe, meinen Sie joggen?
Ja, genau.
Ich jogge kaum deswegen.
Also habe ich jetzt nicht gemacht die letzten zwei Tage.
Okay.
Irgendwo, die Gewicht bemerkt, besonders in den Beinen.
Eine Schwellung?
Nein, habe ich nicht gemerkt.
Okay.
Ich habe nicht gemerkt.
Nein.
Ist Ihnen Uwell oder Schwindelig?
Nein, auch nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Herzrausen, Herzkulopfen?
Es ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay.
Könnten Sie bitte die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Hinter dem Brustkopf oder rechte Seite, linken Seite, können Sie beschreiben?
Ja, es ist genau so mittig.
Genau auf der Brust drauf, mit auch Rückenschmerzen.
Es ist so brennend.
Du kann man das sagen vielleicht.
Sieb die Schmerzen nur brennt.
Ja, nicht drückend oder nicht stechend.
Doch stechend auch, die Schmerzen sind auch stechend.
Stechend brennend würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Wenn Sie legen, sind die Schmerzen verschlechtert.
Wenn ich was?
Wenn Sie legen?
Liegen?
Ja.
Wenn ich lege, habe ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Sind die Schmerzen, die Schmerzen sind nicht immer da,
die Schmerzen treten hin und wieder auf.
Ist das richtig?
Ja, richtig.
Aber in den letzten 2 Tagen oft, immer wieder, ich habe die Schmerzen immer wieder.
Okay, haben Sie Angstgefühl?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ich bin jetzt besorgt, weil mein bekannter gestorben ist,
einem Herzinfarkt.
Ich möchte nicht sterben, ich möchte weiterleben.
Deswegen bin ich hier.
Okay, ja, ich werde sterben.
Ich werde sterben.
Ist Ihnen eine Vorerkrankung bekannt, wie Diabetes, Melitis, Bluthochdruck oder Polystin?
Bekannte?
Ja, bekannte Vorerkrankung.
Bei mir oder bei meinen Bekannten?
Nein, nein, bei Ihnen.
Nein, ich habe keine Vorerkrankungen.
Ich nehme auch keine Medikamente ein.
Ich habe immer noch eine Vorerkrankung.
Ja, das ist jetzt ja, Gott sei Dank.
Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Nehmen Sie Regal-Music Medikamente ein?
Wie gesagt, nein.
Bei Bedarf auch.
Ja, wenn ich meine Grippe habe oder wenn ich Kopfschmerzen habe,
nehme ich mal Ibuprofen ein.
Und Sie haben auch eine Grippe gehabt.
Ich habe jetzt auch oft eine Grippe gehabt und habe ein bisschen mehr Ibuprofen
angenommen.
Winter ist kalt.
Ja, sie haben recht.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie keine Allergie bekannt sind.
Nein, ist mir nicht bekannt.
Ich habe keine Allergie, so weit ich weiß.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden, Herr Ganz?
Noch nie.
Muss ich auch nicht.
Also, ich möchte nicht schon mal operieren.
Okay.
Sind Ihre Eltern gesund oder ist bei Ihnen einige Vorerkrankungen bekannt?
Also, meine Eltern haben beide Bluthochdruck,
die nehmen auch Medikamente dafür ein.
Meine Mutter hat eine Schildbrüste unter Funktion.
Und sie hat, glaube ich, ich bin mir nicht sicher,
dass ich eine Rhythmusstörung am Herzen habe.
Seine Mutter?
Meine Mutter.
Ja, Entschuldigung, Ihre Mutter ja.
Ich weiß aber nicht, welche.
Kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Okay.
Herr Ganz, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Elektroingenieur.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Und haben Sie keine Kinder?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Stress oder Belastung in der Arbeit?
Oder im Sozial- und-
Das übliche, also wir haben immer viel zu tun.
Immer neue Projekte, die wir arbeiten,
jetzt aber nichts Neues, immer das Gleiche eigentlich.
Immer viel Stress.
Okay.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Herr Ganz, auch gegen Corona?
Ja, ich bin dreimal geimpft und einmal habe ich Corona gehabt.
Ansonsten, beim letzten Checkup hat mir der Hausarzt gesagt,
war alles in Ordnung.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein.
Okay.
Herr Ganz, brauchen Sie?
Ja.
Und wie viele Zigaretten rachen Sie täglich?
Eine Packung raufe ich schon, eine Packung.
Und seit wann rachen Sie eine Packung?
Seit ungefähr 20 Jahren, stimmt.
Trinken Sie regellmäßig Alkohol?
Am Wochenende ja, also wenn das regelmäßig ist für Sie,
am Wochenende trinke ich mit den Kumpels oft.
Sind wir oft draußen, dann trinken wir Alkohol.
Was trinken Sie am Wochenende?
Kommt drauf an, also mir weinen manchmal auch etwas härteres.
Und nehmen Sie bitte nicht persönlich, das ist routine Frage.
Hatten Sie schon mal Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ein meiner Jugend, also da habe ich ab und zu mal etwas geraucht,
aber so jetzt aktuell nicht.
Meine Jugend, da war ich noch 17, 18 Jahre alt.
Okay Herr Ganz, ich bin mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Haben Sie noch Fragen oder wollen Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Meinen Sie nicht, aber Herzinfarkt, was glauben Sie?
Kann das sein?
Ja, das kann sein, aber so hat es, muss ich einige Untersuchungen
dünn sagen.
Wir wissen unsere Untersuchungen hat 5-3 Teilen,
erst aufnahmegeschrieben, 5-tangekörperliche Untersuchungen,
am Ende Laboruntersuchungen.
Wir müssen alles durschüren und dann in den
Mittelschritte, dann werden wir zusammen mit der
Rezipration über Ihre Situationen, aber das kann sein.
Also das kann sein, dass Sie Herzinfarkt haben?
Ja, das ist möglich, aber machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen,
Sie sind im Krankenhaus und wir sind eine große Team
und wir werden Sie Ihre Gesundheit wiedergeben.
Okay, dann hoffe ich das mal, ich bin jetzt noch,
jetzt habe ich aber Angst bekommen.
Ich bin noch besorgt als eben.
Sorgen, ich kann nicht deutlich gesagt, ob Sie Herzinfarkt haben
oder Sie haben gesagt, ich könnte es haben.
Ja, das ist ein Verdachtdiagnos.
Das muss nicht unbedingt ein Herzinfarkt sein.
Es ist ein Herzinfarkt, aber ich muss es nicht
in der Arbeit verbreiten und das nicht.
Ich muss das EKG verschreiben und das abnehmen.
Aber Sie haben eben gesagt, es kann sein, jetzt sagen Sie
wahrscheinlich nicht sein.
Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen...
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Deswegen sollten wir jetzt diese Diagnose nicht schüpfen.
Das kann, aber das ist nicht deutlich ein Diagnos.
Das ist ein Verdachtdiagnos.
Es kann auch etwas anderes sein.
Das kann auch etwas anderes sein.
Ja, das kann auch etwas anderes sein.
Zum Beispiel Sie haben eine Angst und Sie haben mit
Ihrem Bekannten etwas Schlechter erlebt
und Sie denken immer, ich habe Herzinfarkt.
Aber manchmal große Stress oder Belastung macht auch
eine Gehe, wie Herzinfarkt, Herzschmerzen oder
Brustschmerzen.
Das ist psychisch bei mir.
Diese sind alles Verdachtdiagnose.
Ich kann nicht direkt die Herzinfarkt oder die
Herzinfarkt oder die Herzinfarkt oder die
Herzinfarkt, das ist eine Situation, ich kann jetzt
momentan nicht sagen.
Aber wir werden danach über Ihren Fall wieder deutlich
sprechen.
Sie müssen geduldig sein, brauchen Sie ein bisschen geduld
und ich muss erst Ihnen körperliche Unterzucht
danach, danach werde ich Bulut abnehmen und
EKG verschreiben.
Am Ende können wir wieder wieder etwas sprechen.
Dann warte ich jetzt hier?
Sie können bitte hier warten
und liegen Sie bitte auf der Liege
und werden Sie körperliche Unterzüge
und danach Bulut abnehmen.
Was machen Sie dann noch heute, wenn ich fragen darf?
Lassen Sie mich wieder nach Hause.
Sie sollten mindestens 24 Stunden hier bleiben,
weil wir Sie kontrollieren müssen.
Danach, wenn keine positive Unterzüge sind,
dann werden wir wieder auf die Liege
und dann auf die Liege und dann auf die
Liege und dann dann auf die Liege und dann
keine positive Befunde gibt,
werden wir sie wieder entlassen.
Okay.
Gut.
Wenn Sie das so sagen, okay.
Also Sie wissen noch nicht ganz genau,
Ich habe nicht alles fertig und die mühsische und die operative Unterrichtung der Methoden
aufgeführt, aber am Ende kann ich etwas sagen.
Okay.
Aber machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen, Sie sind in Krankenhaus, wir können alles
behandeln.
Okay.
Schön.
Wir werden dann hier wieder auf Sie warten, okay?
Alles klar.
Aber Sie haben eine Frage, die Sie haben müssen, dass Sie das Protokoll halten, die
Sie können eine Diagnose haben, aber die Sie fragen, halt.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall?
Ich habe keinen Unfall, nein.
Husten Sie?
Husten hab ich auch nicht.
haben sie Haltschmerzen oder Armschmerzen?
Ja, also ich habe in den letzten zwei Tagen auch ein bisschen Haltschmerzen.
Wenn dieses Brennen kommt, dann habe ich auch ein bisschen Haltschmerzen.
Haben Sie in der Armtaupaus gefühlt, Kaplosigkeit?
Nein.
Haltschmerzen, die ich in der Zeit merkte, ist verändert?
Nein, es ist gleichgeblieben. Ich habe immer schon 85 kg.
Haben Sie auch einen Appetit verändert?
Nein. Also nicht wirklich nein.
Haben Sie dort Brennen, Dolis aufgestoßen?
Ja, ich denke schon, ja.
Haben Sie Magengurpe Schmerzen?
Nein, nach dem Essen habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Aber wenn Sie das jetzt fragen, habe ich so ein bisschen Rotbremt tatsächlich, ja.
Wurden bei Ihnen im Krankenwagen ein EKG geschrieben?
Ich reibe.
Ich bin selber gekommen, nicht mit dem Krankenwagen.
Gibt es, dass die Schmerzen etwas lindert oder verstärkt?
Also ich habe tatsächlich die Schmerzen morgens, am meisten morgens,
um dem Laufe des Tages werden die weniger, aber die sind immer noch da.
Haben Sie Gechwölner beinahe?
Nein, hat der Kollege schon gefragt.
Wenn Sie starke Buruschmerzen haben, gechicht noch etwas derselben Zeit,
zum Beispiel Kaltenschweiß?
Nein.
Das ist was.
Aber ich habe gemerkt, wenn ich dann zum Beispiel Wasser trinke,
dann wird das ein bisschen besser.
Wann hatten Sie die Grippe? Ich habe meine Kollegen fragen.
Ja, das weiß ich schon ein bisschen her, also zwei Monate.
Sie haben nicht Medikamente eingenommen, ja?
Nein, gar nicht.
Ich hab nicht so etwas gesehen.
Ich habe keine Medikamente eingenommen.
Sie haben keine Medikamente eingenommen, ja?
Nein, gar nicht.
Ich habe nichts zu tun, ich habe keine Medikamente zu tun.
Nein, gar nicht. Ich habe nicht zu Hause gehabt.
Okay, danke schön.
Aber Sie haben in der ersten Sacken die Gruppe angemessen.
Ich habe die Gruppe gehabt, der Kollege hat gefragt, ob ich Medikamente nehme.
Als ich die Gruppe gehabt habe, habe ich die Gruppe aufgenommen, weil ich die nicht mehr als Mutter nötig bin.
Aber das ist jetzt auch schon ein bisschen länger.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Treppensteigen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlücken während etwas essen?
Nein, nicht wirklich eigentlich.
Zum Beispiel besonders im Rückenseite während Schlücken.
Nein.
Okay.
Siehne.
Nein.
Okay.
Hallo, Guten Morgen Herr Oberarzt.
Ja, Guten Morgen, wie geht es?
Wenn Sie seithaben, würde ich gerne Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Gerne, wie geht es?
Ja, das ist Herr Ganz, Herr Martin-Gas.
Er ist 40 Jahre alt und 5. Mai 1982 geboren.
Er ist 70 kWh und 85 kg schwer.
Er stellte sich bei uns seit 2 Tagen,
und er hat die
Sie sind in der Schmerz-Intestate liegt bei 6 bis 7 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Sie haben die Schmerz-Intestate in der Schmerz-Intestate geblieben.
Sie haben die Schmerz-Intestate geblieben.
Sie haben keine Schmerz-Intestate geblieben.
Sie haben keine Allergie gekannt und wurden noch nie operiert.
Sie haben die Schmerz-Intestate geblieben.
Sie haben eine Schmerz-Intestate geblieben.
Das war wahrscheinlich eine psychosomatische Krankheit, weil seine Bekannte leiden an Herzkrankheiten.
Ja, er ist gestorben, oder?
Ja, also die müssen wir mal genau überlegen, ob das wirklich auch psychosomatisch sein kann.
Psychosomatisch ist immer eine Ausschlussdiagnose, das heißt, kommt immer am Ende.
Sie müssen jetzt natürlich erstmal die Diagnostik machen.
Das heißt, wenn er tatsächlich Beschwerden hat, und deswegen kommt er in die Ambulanz, weil er auch natürlich Angst hat und besorgt ist,
dass er eventuell einen Herzinfarkt auskriegt haben könnte.
Aber ich denke, wir sollten den Patienten hier im Krankenhaus belassen und dann nochmal ein Ultraschall vom Herzen machen,
ob er vielleicht doch eine KAK haben könnte, vielleicht auch ein Belastungsecker machen können.
Aber was wichtiger ist, ist, glaube ich, dass wir nach einem Ultraschall vielleicht auch mal eine Magenspiegel machen sollten.
Um mal vielleicht auch in die Speiseröhre zu gucken, in die Magen reinzuschauen.
Denn was könnte er noch haben als Differenzialdiagnose? Was ist hier die wahrscheinlichste Diagnose?
Ja, es kann sein.
Genau, es kann sein.
Genau, er trinkt auch Alkohol, haben Sie gefragt, ob er viel Kaffee trinkt?
Nein, ich habe nicht gefragt.
Ich habe oft so, dass die vielleicht auch ein Barrettesufagus haben, am Übergang in die Magenschleimhaut.
Wir sollten hier definitiv gucken, ob er eine entzündliche Erkrankung im Suffagus hat oder Magenbereich hat.
Das müssen wir gucken.
Und ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass er eine psychosomatische Erkrankung hat.
Ich sehe überhaupt nicht eigentlich.
Gut, sagen wir mal, er hat eine Refluxerkrankung, er hat eine gastro-sophagialen Refluxerkrankung, also eine Gert, Gert oder Erd.
Das wissen wir nicht.
Sie müssten eine Madenspiegel machen, eine Sophageur durch den Skopie machen.
Und wie würden Sie den Patienten denn behandeln?
Was würden Sie ihm geben, damit er?
Ja, ich würde gerne ihm Protonpompa Hema verschreiben.
Was würden Sie zum Beispiel verschreiben und wie oft?
Um Prasol, Pantoprasol, 20 Milligramm täglich am Abend.
Aber erste eine Woche würde ich 40 Milligramm geben, danach 20 Milligramm reduziert.
Okay, das hört sich ganz gut an.
Was muss unbedingt bei einer Magenspiegelung oder Ösophageur durch den Skopie mit abgenommen werden?
Was muss gemacht werden? Nicht nur schauen, sondern man muss auch...
Wir müssen ein Probe entnehmen, das ein Biopsy machen.
Und damit werden wir Helicobacterpulori auszuschließen.
Ja, richtig. Es kommt immer auf den Befund an.
Aber da müssten natürlich auch die Beschreibung von den Patienten passt eher nicht zu einer Gastritis,
sondern eher zu einer Ösophagitis.
Und da müssten Proben auch vom Ösophagus stufen, wie obszenent genommen werden.
Muss geguckt werden, was für eine Ösophagitis sein könnte.
Es kommt natürlich auf makroskopisch an, also was man sieht, aber auch auf histologisch.
Deswegen ist es extrem wichtig, dass man guckt, was er ist.
Er könnte auch eine Sore-Ösophageitis haben.
Geht auch. Also eine Pilzbesiedlung zum Beispiel.
Er könnte auch eine Eosophageitis haben.
Er ist auch in der letzten Zeit sehr oft...
Er könnte einen Barrett-Ösophagus haben.
Er könnte auch eine Ösophagus-Karzinom haben.
Geht auch alles. Also könnte sein, hoffen wir natürlich nicht.
Deswegen ist es extrem wichtig, dass man, wenn jemand kommt, mit Torachsschmerzen
oder mit Bussschmerzen, natürlich als erstes an einen Herzinfarkt denkt.
Aber als Zweitiagnose muss man natürlich auch an Ösophagitis denken.
Eventuell sogar Orten an Errissma.
Daran muss man denken, kann auch eine Interkostalneuralgie haben.
Er könnte auch zum Beispiel einfach einen...
Er könnte sogar einen Herbiszoster haben.
Eine Hauterscheinung.
Man muss ihn körperlich genau untersuchen.
Es gibt viele Differenzialdiagnose.
Es gibt alles, was mit Torachsschmerzen kommt
und was auch mit Rauchen zusammenhängen.
Also er hat ja ein risikoprofil, ein kardiovaskilieres Risikoprofil.
Nicht alles ist ein Herzinfarkt.
Es könnte natürlich auch eine Ösophagitis sein.
Was empfehlen Sie dem Patienten denn,
außer, dass er Prozonenpumpenenebeteuren nehmen sollte?
Was empfehlen Sie ihm noch?
Was sollte er aufpassen?
Was sollte er machen?
Man kann Antisauere.
Antazida.
Zum Beispiel Talzitz.
So etwas, oder Gaviscon kann er machen.
Aber was empfehlen Sie solchen Patienten,
die eine Reflexerkrankung oder eine Ösophagitis haben?
Er hat jetzt nur eine kastro-Ösophagel-Reflex
und das ist ein Ösophagitis.
Was empfehlen Sie dem Patienten?
Ich würde gerne empfehlen,
dass der Patient Rauchen gehören sollte.
Mit dem Rauchen aufhören sollte.
Mit dem Rauchen aufgehören.
Aufhören sollte, er sollte auch Alkohol reduzieren.
Vielleicht ist der Patient abends sehr viel.
Er kann sein, dass er vor dem Schlafengehen essen ist.
Viel Fastfood ist.
Er sollte auch gucken, dass er nicht so viel Ibuprofen nimmt.
Er sollte gucken, dass er an Gewicht verliert.
Er sollte gucken, dass er vielleicht mit Oberkörper-Hochlagerung schläft.
Er sollte kohlenhydratarm essen.
Mehr Eiweißreich essen.
Das sollte er machen.
Gut, das ist alles, was wir jetzt so sprechen sollten.
Gibt es noch Fragen von Ihnen?
Haben Sie etwas, was Sie ergänzen möchten?
Was ich vergessen haben könnte?
Wichtig ist, dass man nicht bei jedem,
ich habe es eben schon erwähnt,
dass man auch an Differenzialdiagnosen denkt.
Das ist ein brennendem Charakter.
Wenn ein Brennend sagt, immer gucken, ob er auch Wasser ist, wann er ist.
Wie er schläft, ob er dick ist, ob er dünn ist.
Das ist immer ganz wichtig,
dass Sie da immer auch an die Differenzialdiagnosen denken.
Vielen Dank.